if you are someone who has been training
for a while you you think you're
training pretty smart you think you're
training pretty hard uh you're doing
training that should be effective but
you just look around and you think man
like I I just don't seem to be
experiencing the gains that a lot of
other people in my gym are my training
partners are I don't seem to be getting
the responses to training that I see
Elsewhere on social media what are some
things that I could potentially do to
help Rectify that and and start making
better gains
um so the first thing you can do and
this is
may sound like a bit of a cop-out but
it's true it's just try to make sure you
have your ducks in a row outside the gym
so
you know if you're not
experiencing particularly large strength
gains training doesn't seem to be going
well but you're consistently sleeping
four or five hours per night uh just
because you're getting up to tomfoolery
you can't turn off Netflix can't get off
social media like your lifestyle would
theoretically allow you to sleep eight
or nine hours per night but just just
due to sheer pig-headedness you're
sleeping five hours per night like I
don't know maybe try to address that
before you say like I just don't respond
well to training
um or you know if you uh have the means
to consume like 1.6 grams of protein per
kilogram body mass but uh you just don't
like to and so you're consuming like 40
grams of protein per day
ah you know if you're not experiencing
much muscle growth that could be
contributing so I I don't want to make
it sound like everyone has the same
capacity to fully get their ducks in a
row outside the gym like you know if if
poor sleep and Recovery is uh leading to
smaller strength gains less muscle
growth but the reason that you're not
sleeping as much is because you recently
had kids or because you have to work two
jobs to make ends meet or any number of
other things like you know I I I don't
want to make it sound like oh yeah like
if you don't do if you don't uh design
your lifestyle to look like a
professional athlete it's because you
don't want it bad enough like I'm
certainly not saying that but to to the
extent that is feasible if there are
ways that you can improve your nutrition
improve your recovery that you simply
haven't done to this point even though
they're they're feasible and reasonable
for you to do so maybe try those things
first yeah that really hits close to
home right now because as you know
um we had a hurricane rolling into town
and so what does my girlfriend do she
just leaves you know she just gets out
of town and leaves me with the cat
unbelievable so I'm over here trying to
take care of the cat it's it's a
full-time job trying to take care of one
cat so like my sleep my schedule it's
all out the way window you know so I'm
I'm doing my best but man chasing Izzy
around the house has not been easy it's
tough to be a single dad yeah yeah uh so
the next thing you can do and this this
is going to sound quite obvious
um but it needs to be said is just keep
training so if you're experiencing
relatively small or relatively slow
gains in Fitness uh gains and strength
gains in muscle mass Etc
small gains do add up over time
um and you know that that is almost
self-evidently true but let's bring
bring a study into it just so we can
look at some data so this study is from
Ross and colleagues from 2015 the title
is separate effects of intensity and
amount of exercise on inter-individual
cardiorespiratory Fitness response uh
and so in this group uh or in this study
three different groups of people trained
five times per week for 24 weeks one of
the groups basically just trained easy
so in in each of their training sessions
um the total amount of work they did was
relatively small and they performed it
at a low intensity in another group they
also exercised at a low intensity but uh
the total volume of work they did was
twice as large as the first group and
then the third group uh they did a lot
of work per session and they also
trained at a higher intensity city than
the other two groups and what you see in
all three groups so they they assess
cardio respiratory Fitness at four weeks
eight weeks 16 weeks and 24 weeks and in
all three groups which you see
is that after just four weeks of
training there were
quite a few individuals in every group
that would be classified as
non-responders including the group that
was doing quite a lot of training so a
high volume of training and at a high
intensity
um 11 out of 31 subjects would have been
classified as non-responders after four
weeks uh and in the group basically just
training easy so low intensity and a low
total volume of training uh 20 out of 34
subjects would have been classified as
non-responders so those were people who
experienced uh either increases or
decreases in aerobic fitness that were
smaller than the than the typical
measurement error for the equipment they
were using but then after 24 weeks of
training in the really easy training
group the number of non-responders had
gone down from 20 to 15 in kind of that
middle group the higher volume of low
intensity training the number of
non-responders had gone down from 25 to
just nine and in the high intensity and
high volume group the number of
non-responders had gone down from 11 to
zero so you know just simply continuing
the same training intervention
will just lead to larger gains over time
um as long as you are making progress
progress adds up
uh and this isn't like over like a
four-year timeline and we're talking
about 24 weeks right yeah it's six
months yeah
uh the next thing you can do if you're
not experiencing the the sorts of gains
you would like to see is in
again like this will potentially seem
obvious but again it Bears sane is just
to train more or train harder so the the
prior study is a great illustration of
this uh the the paper by Ross so you
know as the amount of training increases
so the total volume and as the intensity
of training increased the average gains
in cardiorespiratory Fitness got larger
and the proportion of people who would
have been classified as non-responders
got smaller another study that I'm
pretty sure we've talked about on the
podcast before also relates to this this
was by Montero and lundby in 2017 title
is refuting the myth of non-response to
exercise training colon non-responders
do respond to higher dose of training
that's a good way to get people to read
your paper or talk about it if your
first thing is refuting the myth of
blank yeah just like a a really strong
audacious declaratory statement men at
minimum that's going to get people to
click on your study it is I I said that
a little bit facetiously but I I
genuinely do appreciate it because like
we go through the journal sweep every
month for mass and we you know we sort
it by title and there's no fewer than
like 75 studies that that just start
with effects of some boring [ __ ] on some
other [ __ ] yeah you know so I I
appreciate a bold title oh for sure uh I
I mean look click bait Works folks
whether whether you like it or not and
we're like buzz or like clickbait works
just as well in on PubMed as it does on
BuzzFeed or like YouTube like it's
generalizably true we live in the world
of Click bait it's time to just accept
it
um you know and here's the deal as well
like occasionally we'll put a clickbait
title on something and people in the
comments like not many but occasionally
they'll be like ah this is clickbait
you clicked on it though that's that's
all I'm saying like congratulations you
played yourself it worked yeah um anyway
so
in this study there were five groups of
people uh who trained for six weeks uh
at 60 minutes per session and uh the
groups either trained one two three four
or five times per week and so basically
the total volume of training and
training intensity was the same in all
five groups so the total of all total
volume of training was simply determined
by how many days per week they were
training uh and they found that for the
groups training one two and three times
per week there were a reasonable number
of folks who were non-responders in
those groups again people experiencing
gains in aerobic fitness that were
smaller than the measurement error for
for the device being used to assess
Fitness and there were more
non-responders training ones per week
than twice per week and more
non-responders training twice per week
than three times per week and there were
no people who would who would have been
classified as non-responders in the four
and five times per week groups and then
in the second part of the study they
took the folks who were classified as
non-responders during the first six
weeks and said hey you're going to do
six more weeks of training but you're
gonna do an additional two sessions per
week so if you were previously just
training once per week now you're gonna
train three times per week if you're
training two times per week now you're
gonna train four times per week and if
you were training three times per week
now you're gonna be training five times
per week so those same people who were
previously deemed non-responders
following their first six weeks of
training they just do more training for
another six weeks and uh tldr uh none of
them were non-responders anymore just
increasing the dose of exercise
increased the extent to which they
responded to it and like this this
likely generalizes to resistance
training as well like we know that uh
training volume is a factor that is
strongly associated with hypertrophy
response answers so you know if you're
if you're not seeing the muscle growth
you want and your training is overall
fairly low volume
like you'll probably respond better to
training by increasing that volume a
little bit
all right uh so those those are I think
the most obvious things you could do
just uh stick at it uh try to get your
ducks in a row outside the gym and uh
just try training more yeah I was
smiling because I know someone's gonna
get in the comments and say like oh Greg
thanks for the evidence-based segment
that tells people to to do more and do
better yeah I I mean but
like that is true uh but like I I do
think it's worth so
a dynamic that I think exists is
um like folks who respond worse to
training than most people on average uh
like if they do say anything about it uh
or you know maybe complain about it a
little bit like they'll often be met
with just a wall of responses saying
like well have you tried trying like
like why don't you just train harder
um and like that I think is often mint
in kind of a
um
ah what's the way not off-putting what
like it's it's just like kind of in a
dismissive way yeah
um so what I'm at least attempting to do
here is to not assume that everyone
who's responding worse to training than
average isn't trying and isn't putting
in the work
um like I I fully I fully believe they
are and they they just got a bad genetic
draw and like it is what it is yeah and
so I'm trying to say like couched within
that context
unfortunately it is still true that
training more will probably be
beneficial and I don't mean that in like
a dismissive way like I just mean it in
a it is probably true way yeah and we've
mentioned in the past in various places
that we do tend to lean toward the
empiricist perspective when it comes to
you know reviewing evidence and I do
think it's it's beneficial it's very
easy to say well if you just do it for
longer I assume it will start working I
think it is very reassuring to say oh
yeah here is empirical evidence of
people who in the first phases of
training struggled but those gains did
materialize over time like it is nice to
have that confirmation even though it's
not a dazzling theory of do it for
longer yeah you know I I mean a good
chunk of science is just confirming
things that we already very strongly
suspected to be true yeah and this is
just kind of in that category yeah all
right uh so the fourth thing you could
do is just measure more variables
um here is another nice uh strong
declaratory audacious statement from
churchward Vin and colleagues in 2015.
title of this study is there are no
non-responders to resistance type
exercise training in older men and women
um you know it's another great thing
about title start started to uh butt in
here but yeah not only are they more fun
and clickable but if you were the type
of person who only reads abstracts with
this one you don't even have to do that
that is true you just read the title
correct wow I know everything I wanted
to know yeah and I mean the title itself
is a pretty good tldr
um so in this study it was a
retrospective analysis of responses to
12 and 24 weeks of training in uh men
and women who were at least 65 years old
at the start of the study and uh pre and
post training they assessed lean body
mass via dexa type 1 and type 2 muscle
fiber cross-sectional area via biopsy
one rep max strength for leg press and
knee extensions and physical function
test chair rise time test those were
assessed at Baseline after 12 weeks of
training and after 24 weeks of training
and the thing to note is in this study
there were plenty of quote unquote
non-responders for each discrete
variable like there were plenty of
people who didn't gain that much lean
mass plenty of people who didn't
experience robust increases in fiber
cross-sectional area a handful of people
people who didn't experience strength
gains Etc but every single individual in
this study
experienced meaningful increases in at
least one of these things so like and
the other thing to note kind of going
back to the to the second point of just
keep training for each discrete variable
there were fewer people who were deemed
non-responders at 24 weeks then at 12
weeks and and here are two good quotes
just from the abstract
non-responsiveness was not apparent in
any subject as a positive adaptive
response on at least one training
outcome was apparent in every subject
and quote the level of responsiveness
was strongly affected by the duration of
the exercise intervention with more
positive responses following more
prolonged exercise training so
like
this this will also I think be
hard to say without
potentially coming off as dismissive but
like there are there are benefits to
training that you probably care about
that may not be the the number one main
thing you're interested in that if you
just kind of are willing to expand the
scope of the responses that you're that
you're willing to be interested in and
assess and look at
there will probably be something that's
going right for you so
if you're trying to
you know just just gain as much muscle
as possible head to toe put on some
strength Etc uh and you're you're a low
responder to hypertrophy style training
you know it could be that that becoming
a mass monster isn't in the cards but
you might have a muscle group or two
that responds pretty well so if you get
more granular with your assessments and
instead of just looking at like total
lean mass you kind of look at like oh
I'm gonna take a upper arm circumference
measure lower arm circumference measure
upper thigh calf waist chest whatever
like you might find a few muscles that
do respond pretty well you can keep
track of them be proud of them uh if
you're trying to build muscle and get
stronger like there are
just fewer strength non-responders than
hypertrophy non-responders
um so I mean like even if you're not
putting that much muscle on your frame
you will probably still get stronger and
become generally more physically capable
like there there are
positive training related things that
are happening which may not necessarily
be the the just level A1 type thing you
were the most interested in
um you know like like there there will
probably still be plenty of of uh
physical aspects that are moving in the
right direction so if you're willing to
just kind of like expand your horizons
and look at more total variables you
will probably find something that that
is going pretty well for you I'm glad
that you brought up the term mass
monster because it is something I wanted
to clear up a lot of people have asked
me why I trans because I had a really
good thing going I was a very successful
Pro natural bodybuilder and a lot of
people ask why I transitioned to Pro
natural classic bodybuilding which is a
pretty huge change of direction for me
and it really comes down to like for
some people being a mass monster just
isn't in the cards like you mentioned
but you know for me it was more of a
stylistic thing I was looking around the
the natural bodybuilding landscape
and it was just getting grotesque I mean
you had these Mass monsters getting on
stage 160
165 pounds on these Pro natural
bodybuilding stages so I'm glad that
that we've expanded the sport and opened
up classic bodybuilding for a more
a more streamlined and frankly less
grotesque physique yeah totally fair
yeah uh okay so the the fifth thing you
could potentially do is experiment with
different training Styles so uh I'm
gonna go back to the carniero paper that
I uh talked about quite a bit two
episodes ago uh title is different load
intensity transition schemes to avoid
plateau and no response and lean body
mass gain in post-menopausal women and
so I'm not going to talk about this
study in a ton of detail again because I
I already did two episodes ago
um but just as a very brief refresher
this was a 24-week crossover study where
subjects completed 12 weeks of training
at a moderate intensity so 8 to 12 rep
max loads and 12 weeks of training at a
low intensity so 27 to 31 rep max loads
in a randomized order so half of them
started with moderate load training for
12 weeks followed by low load training
for 12 weeks and the other half just
went the opposite order 12 weeks of low
load training followed by 12 weeks of
moderate load training
and as I discussed in the previous
segment
some individuals who did really really
well with moderate load training really
didn't do well with low load training
they experienced a ton of hypertrophy
training in the 8 to 12 or at max range
and experienced either much smaller
gains in hypertrophy or even experience
decreases in lean soft tissue mass of
the thighs following 12 weeks of low
load training and vice versa some people
did really really well with low load
training and just really didn't get much
if anything out of moderate load
training so it could simply be a matter
of uh finding a training style that that
works well for you which may not be the
training style that works the best on
average and specifically to this
conversation about low responders High
responders to training non-responders to
training
um one thing we can do with the data in
this in this study since uh like since
individual results were reported is you
can just look to see uh following 12
weeks of training who would have been
termed a low responder to train versus a
high responder to training just using a
median split like who got better gains
than average versus who got worse gains
than average uh well not average 50th
percentile you know what I'm saying
um and then after 24 weeks so after an
additional 12 weeks of training who who
who who was previously a high responder
is now still a high responder uh versus
who was a low responder who is now a
high responder who is a who is a low
responder who's still a low responder
who was a high responder who's now a low
responder you know just just looking to
see how many of those categorizations
would have been shuffled up and then
also
um you know during the first 12 weeks of
training how many people would have
initially been termed non-responders who
suddenly became responders after an
additional 12 weeks of training with a
different training style and again
non-responder being defined here as
people who experienced increases in lean
soft tissue mass of the thigh that were
smaller than the kind of technical
measurement error of the machine being
used and so when you do that analysis
a full third of the people uh in this
study their uh like High versus low
responder classification would have
flipped so uh out of 24 total people in
the study
um
eight of them flipped so either they
were previously High responders after 12
weeks of training and became low
responders after 24 weeks of training or
they were low responders after 12 weeks
of training and became High responders
after 24 weeks of training and at times
this was actually a a pretty
pretty intense changes so uh just
looking at at the individual results
following the full 24 weeks of training
the individuals in the study who
experienced the third and fourth most
total amount of hypertrophy following
the full 24 weeks of training would have
been classified as low responders
following the first 12 weeks of training
so you know that that's uh just just
Downstream of spending 12 weeks of
training doing a style of training that
they simply responded much much better
to than they did the style of training
in the first 12 weeks and then for
responders versus non-responders like in
in 12-week studies we typically see that
between like a quarter and a third of
folks you would term non-responders like
people who experience gains and strength
or gains in muscle mass smaller than
kind of the typical measurement error
just day-to-day biological variability
uh and that's what we saw in this study
after 12 weeks so out of 24 subjects
seven of them would have been termed
non-responders after the first three
months of training they experienced
gains in lean soft tissue mass of the
thighs that were smaller than the
measurement error of the machine after
24 weeks of training only two people
would have still been termed
non-responders so both continuing to
train and finding a training style that
worked better for them cut the
non-response rate down from 7 out of 24
to 2 out of 24. so
um
yeah like
it's
I I think that people
on the whole
uh do
do have maybe a bit too much faith in
kind of the the uh Collective
unconscious of the fitness community and
not enough faith in
their own experience and their their
ability to interpret their own
experience like I I see a lot of people
who uh you know go online and say like
hey I want to get stronger what programs
will help me do that they look around
they find a program that a lot of people
have done generally has good reviews
seem to work well and they do it and it
doesn't work particularly well for them
either they don't get stronger at all or
they don't get much stronger and they
just kind of throw their hands up and
say well this is a good program it works
like it's worked for thousands of people
it didn't seem to work for me so man
like I I guess getting stronger just
isn't in the cards
um
whereas like I think probably a more
productive thing to do would be
either to look at kind of what the what
the characteristics of that training
program where the the overall level of
volume overall level of intensity uh
training frequency
and and just say like okay that didn't
work let's just do the opposite like if
it was a low volume program let's try a
high volume program if it was a high
intensity program let's try a lower
intensity program and just and just you
know basically start troubleshooting
from there like I know what what didn't
work let's just try something different
and see if that works or you know just
kind of going back to the well and
saying hey let's try to find another
generally effective pretty well reviewed
program that doesn't look anything at
all like that one that didn't work for
me like that's
um I I think that uh more people should
do that like don't don't uh so I mean in
this this can even
go to levels that I
like I don't want to sound mean but to
to an extent that like I find I have a
difficult time empathizing with uh like
like someone will start training and get
on generally it's just like a typical
linear progression type program like
starting strength strong lift something
like that and they put in two years
under the bar uh on a single training
program and
like they've been hitting a wall
deloading building back up hitting the
wall deloading building back up over
that entire time span
never built much muscle never got
particularly stronger but it's like well
people say these are good programs and I
should be able to write it to a 405
Squad and I only squat
220. so like I guess I just need to keep
doing this
um
and then you know they just don't get
there and decide like oh well resistance
train just isn't for me or I must be
[ __ ] up and doing something wrong
I would say like the only thing you
[ __ ] up there is just sticking with a
program for two years that clearly
doesn't work for you yeah um yeah like I
I I I don't know like this is another
rant but I I think that like the
there's been so much so much invective
thrown the way of of pro quote-unquote
program Hoppers over the years then now
there are a lot of people who are afraid
to ever change their training program
yeah
um
and yeah like sometimes you just need to
change your training program yeah I was
gonna ask you about that because you
know you you look at
um you know you you talked about you
know things you can do about it keep
training yeah potentially train more
train harder and those two uh approaches
you know someone who's who is very uh
you know someone who speaks very poorly
of quote-unquote program Hoppers they're
they're hearing that and saying Hell
yeah that's exactly what I've been
saying but but you know it is important
to recognize that simply trying more
than one thing does not make you a
program Hopper right so like yeah if you
if you try a program and and within the
first four to eight weeks it's not
working but you gen generally enjoy it
you know maybe that is a situation where
you say okay well maybe you know try
some modifications to do a little more
alter volume intensity or maybe just
stick with it for eight more weeks and
see if the needle starts moving but yeah
like you said I mean the the two things
that that do get a little bit baffling
is the people who
are 200 pounds away from their squat
goal you know it's they've been doing
this program it's got them like 10
pounds over the last year and it's like
if you think you're gonna make up the
next 200 pounds how is that going to
occur yeah unless you're going to be
doing this for 40 years and and like
that's the the plan here you know like
just mathematically how do you think of
doing the same thing with this rate of
progress is going to get you to where
where your stated goal is well if
scientists ever solve human aging like
yeah and now you have a 500 year Runway
maybe yeah but but you you do sometimes
see these situations where you're like
you extrapolate out the gains you're
getting and if anything they're going to
get worse not better over time if you
keep doing you know it should be
somewhat logarithmic generally speaking
Yeah doing the same exact approach
um but yeah you look at it and you're
like maybe program hopping you know with
a little caveat that you're giving the
program enough time to do something
maybe that's actually the right path
forward uh and like you said there's
also a tendency in the space for people
to be so hung up on the collective
understanding that they reject their own
experience that's literally right in
front of their eyes and like I have
observed some internet chatter where
someone's like you know I tried this
program that has less set volume than
the going meta-analysis that Everyone
likes and it seemed to work for me but
that's impossible and it's like well
it's not though yeah it literally
happened yeah and we should expect a
great deal of variability from person to
person because of all the reasons you've
covered so it is important that like
some people are so uh dismissive of
program Hoppers that some people get
locked into this area where they're like
well whatever works for everyone has to
be best for me and if I ever change that
then I've demonstrated a lack of
commitment to the program which is bad
yes yeah yeah so if you're if you're
trying new training programs every two
weeks
yeah then you're a program Hopper like
yeah you got to give it time to see if
it's working but if you've been on a
program for three to six months uh uh
and and you've given it a real honest
shot and it's not doing much for you try
something else like that that's not
program hopping that's uh
like I know this is an apocryphal quote
but the the quote that's often
attributed to Einstein like insanity is
doing the same thing over and over and
expecting a different response
um
I I think that applies here yeah
all right and then uh the last thing
that you could potentially do is take an
even more uh expansive view of the
benefits you would like to see from
training
um
and or potentially not just try a
different style of programming for a
particular Fitness outcome but
potentially just see if there's other
forms of training that that click better
with you so uh for example like
you could very well be a low responder
for strength and hypertrophy and still
experience great improvements in blood
pressure blood lipids bone health uh
mood sleep
um
uh decreasing the rate of cognitive
aging improved blood glucose regulation
and probably a half dozen other things
from continuing to train so like you may
not be seeing the gains in muscle mass
that you want uh or strength that you
want but training could still be doing a
ton of other positive things for you
that you know like like ultimately
ultimately I I think that
when you look back on it uh
uh as you're getting older like you're
you're probably not going to be like
that resentful or upset that you weren't
like the biggest guy at every gym you
went into but if you're you know getting
into your 70s and you're still in pretty
good health and you look around at some
of your other peers who didn't really do
much consistent exercise throughout
their lifespan and their like things are
starting to go downhill for them a
little bit you'll say you know what I
never got as big as I wanted to but I'm
I'm glad I did all of that training yeah
um
and then for like on the topic of of
trying to maybe see if there's just an
entirely different style of training
that you've responded well to and that
you like
um a study that I want to talk about by
car avirta and colleagues from 2011 uh
individual responses to combined
endurance and strength training in older
adults there were 53 sub there were
three groups in this study I'm only
going to talk about one of them but
there was a group of 53 subjects who did
21 weeks of both resistance and
endurance training uh and there's a
figure from the study that we can put up
on the screen here if you're watching on
YouTube uh but just looking at the
correlation in gains in VO2 Peak and uh
maximum voluntary contraction strength I
think I think of the quads is what they
were measuring
um there was no correlation at all
between those two things like people who
responded well to endurance training or
to the aerobic part of the intervention
um like that like responding well in
terms of gains in VO2 Peak was
completely unpredictive of whether you
would also gain a lot of strength uh if
you gained a lot of strength that was
completely unpredictive of whether you'd
experience large gains in aerobic
fitness uh and so
you know I I think that
um
I think that
oftentimes like
I I think a lot of this comes back to
like motivation almost like what why are
you training in the first place like
what what are you hoping to get out of
it uh and like I've I've talked to quite
a few people who
like
had been Lifting for a long like they
hit me up because they'd been Lifting
for a while and they they just weren't
seeing the responses to training that
they wanted
um and you know
like I would be asking them like hey why
why are you doing this in the first
place like what what are you hoping to
achieve it's like oh well I'm trying to
get as as muscular and strong as
possible and it's like
yeah but why like what's what's
underpinning that and like for for a few
of them it was like well you know like
I've I've heard that it's it's good for
longevity like people who are who have
more strength and more muscle mass when
they hit like 50 60 years old tend to
have longer lifespans like ultimately
I'm just doing this to try to be healthy
so it's like man so first you don't you
don't need to be a mass monster in the
first place to do that
um
and second like if you're hitting me up
because you're you're so frustrated
about the the relatively poor responses
you're seeing to resistance training
you know that like
doing aerobic training is also good for
longevity uh why don't you give that a
shot and a handful of them gave it a
shot and they're like you know what like
I don't know why I was lifting in the
first place I never particularly liked
it it wasn't fun and uh guess what I
like biking or I like running thanks for
putting me down this road and so on one
hand kind of shooting myself in the foot
because I don't I don't put out aerobic
training information that is taking a
potential future customer out of my
revenue streams but uh ultimately I mean
I don't know man uh like so so
ultimately if you if you like lifting
um like if you're if you're coming at
this from a like like purely intrinsic
motivation like a lot of this shouldn't
really be an issue in the first place
like you know maybe you would just like
to see larger gains because you'd like
to make larger gains
um but if you have like a true intrinsic
motivation here especially if you're
kind of like process oriented about it
and you're lifting because you like to
lift uh you probably won't be the type
of person who's getting like super super
frustrated about this because like
whether or not you're getting super huge
and super strong like you're continuing
to lift because you like to uh if you've
made it to this point in the video
and
you're still thinking like man like I I
really want to be as big and strong as
possible but like this is really
frustrating because like
I don't really even like lifting that
much I just want what I can get out of
like what I've been told I will get out
of lifting
I think at that point it's it may not be
a terrible idea to just like assess
motivation and see like why are you
doing this in the first place because I
gotta tell you like I I also know plenty
of people who do respond really well to
training
who just like didn't like training all
that much and guess what they don't
stick with training
um like they just don't like they get
big and get strong and then just get
bored of it in five years and say yeah
like [ __ ] it I never liked doing that
I'm going to stop and then for them it
becomes like a fun fact where later in
life they're like oh yeah like 20 years
ago I was huge would you even believe it
yeah yeah yeah so you know if you're
if you are like that that frustrated
that that does suggest at least to some
extent a lack of like process oriented
intrinsic motivation so if you're going
down that road it it probably wouldn't
be a terrible idea to just try some
completely different form of exercise
that regardless of the gains you get
from it you just like doing it it's it's
fun and so so you're going to be much
more likely to stick with it and there
is a decent chance that if you're
frustrated because of the lack of gains
you're getting to resistance training
you very well could respond very well to
some other form of exercise like you
know maybe you've been Lifting for two
or three years you're not particularly
big you're not particularly strong you
start doing some aerobic training and
six months later you have a very
competitive 5K time like that that may
just be a more productive road to go
down yeah and I think this conversation
about broadening your horizons about
what training can look like and what it
can bring you that really resonates with
me in a way that really didn't have
anything to do with being frustrated
with my response to training like you
know that I've had a thing going on for
quite some time now with uh kind of like
a nerve entrapment that has made it very
very difficult to do
uh just about any squad or deadlift
variations without a pretty substantial
amount of pain
um like the type of pain that actually
isn't just like achy but really Alters
kind of day-to-day enjoyment of of Life
yeah uh and so you know I had the the
road to road to Athens segment where I
was like oh maybe I'll get back into
long distance running now unfortunately
that aggravated the exact same thing and
So eventually that became uh similarly
frustrating but it was the same idea of
like can I find a way to do exercise
that is enjoyable and brings me some of
these benefits like obviously it's not
going to make me huge but
how will it affect my mood my sleep
thing you know aging things like that so
uh what you know whether you're running
into frustration because of uh you know
lack of progress you know being
dissatisfied with your gains or you're
running into frustration because of the
way you like to train is currently not
compatible with what makes you feel good
and you have to make some uh some
adjustments whether they're temporary or
permanent uh pertaining to some
limitations it is sometimes helpful to
go back to the drawing board and have a
broader scope of what exercise looks
like and what it can do for you yeah
yeah and I think just on kind of like a
metal level
um like I I think that it's worth asking
like whether you plan on like competing
in anything uh because like if you do
then it is probably worth being at least
a little concerned about like oh like
how how large are the are the gains I'm
experiencing how do my results stack up
to other people but like if not
the thing is like exercise is just good
uh aerobic exercise is good group
exercise is good resistance exercise is
good like
it's just good to find things that get
you moving and so if if you don't have
like competitive aspirations in any
particular strength physique sport
aerobic sport like anything
just find just find things you enjoy
doing
um
and that should I mean that that should
take care of a lot of it
um
I mean yeah like there have been there
have been plenty of things in my I'm
like so I think a pretty good example
for me at least like historically is
basketball like I've made no bones about
it basketball is my favorite sport I
like the way they dribble up and down
the court little little throwback for
the 90s kids listening
um but like that's a great lyric by the
way who was that Lil battle it was
little bow wow yeah I think from like
Mike yeah uh but yeah so I mean dude I'm
I'm like 5 10 on a good day uh and
I'm like relatively fast can jump
reasonably well have reasonably good
hand-eye coordination but like once I
got onto like the AAU circuit and like
uh like higher levels of basketball like
I mean I just I didn't pick the right
parents for it and so you know like I I
went from being among the better players
in like youth leagues I played in and
like uh for the school I played at to
being like one of the worst players uh
and you know on some of the teams I I
was on I didn't get that much time off
of the bench but like I don't know I
didn't care uh it was boring to sit on
the bench during the games but uh I mean
practice was still sick like because I
just love playing basketball
um
and so like yeah like I I had a strong
intrinsic motivation to keep doing it
even though at least at that level the
the results that I was seeing for the
work I was putting in were way way
smaller than than those of my peers but
I was like this is this is fine because
I I just like doing it it's fun yeah um
and so I mean it and I think one of the
things that helped me a lot with that is
like
I was competitive in the in the sense of
like you know this this is a sport
they're keeping score there's a winner
and a loser but by that time like in
high school
I already had the mindset of like
I can I can see where I'm at in this
sport like I'm not getting a D1
scholarship to play at the next level
I'm certainly not going pro so like
I'm doing this for fun and it's it's a
good time
um and so like yeah that's uh I that's a
perspective just just to keep in mind
like if you're doing something to
compete might be worth comparing
yourself against others if you're really
just doing it for personal satisfaction
longevity whatever
just just find things you like doing
um and if what you like doing that gets
you active differs from what someone on
the Internet is saying
you should be doing just ignore them
because
there's a extremely good chance they're
wrong like whatever sort of exercise you
like is almost assuredly good exercise
yep all right so let's just wrap this up
uh let's do it just a little a little
recap here uh and and some some
implications so the first thing
I'm going all the way back to the
beginning is almost no matter what
you're experiencing in the gym if you're
concerned man like I think I think
there's something wrong with me like
things don't seem to be going right
just take a deep breath it's okay there
is an incredibly good chance that
whatever you're experiencing is
completely normal completely okay
completely fine there's just
a tremendous degree of variability in
terms of the responses people see to
training
um that is like the the variability is
larger than I think people realize and
whatever you're experiencing is probably
within two standard deviations of the
mean very normal [ __ ] it's just people
experience very different responses to
training and and that applies to both
above and below average responses like
if you think like oh [ __ ] like am I am I
the god of resistance training because
I've only been lifting six months and I
squat 405 like no probably not like
you're doing better than average but
you're probably like that that is also
perfectly normal as well like it's above
average but that's that's not an outlier
response whatever you're experiencing is
probably just normal and fine
um
the next thing is uh
like just keep in mind as you're out
there on the internet
um or in or even in the gym like what
you see on a day-to-day basis that you
might be comparing yourself against uh
is almost assured to be a skewed sample
so uh like that's clearly true for
social media like the the people who pop
up in your discover feed or whatever for
physique Sports strength Sports whatever
those are almost always people who just
have very above average responses to
resistance training uh folks find that
interesting that's why they get more
likes that's why the algorithms are
serving them to you
um so what what you come across online
is an extremely skewed sample and if
you're using that to set your
expectations there's there's a decent
chance you'll you'll probably wind up
disappointed and think that even if
you're having like the perfectly average
response to training you will still
perceive it to be below average because
it's below the average of what you're
seeing on social media on a day-to-day
basis but what you're seeing on social
media is a severely skewed sample
um but even like what you see in the gym
is probably at least to some extent a
skewed sample as well like if if you go
in the weight room and most people at
your gym who you see lifting weights all
the time if they tend to be quite a bit
larger or uh stronger than you like that
is probably also a skewed sample because
the thing is like folks tend to
self-select into the forms of exercise
they respond well to and so if you're
seeing the same regulars going to the
gym all the time over months or years
those people who stick with training are
are generally people who have
on average above average responses to
training and that's probably why why
they stick with it compared to some
other form of exercise and this
generalizes as well like the people who
uh like if you go down to a local 5K
like not even some sort of like super
prestigious track and field event the
people competing in that 5K probably
have at least slightly better responses
to aerobic training than the average
person does which is why they're the
type of person who runs 5Ks and likes
doing that so
um yeah don't don't be hard on yourself
and just keep in mind that that what
you're seeing like there's a pretty
decent chance that you are being too
hard on yourself and thinking that what
you're experiencing is
further below average than it actually
is like plenty of power like and this is
true for competitors as well like plenty
of power lifters who
aren't even that competitive at local
meets maybe great responders to
resistance training it's just they're
not great responders to resistance
training compared to other people who
compete in this sport so
just keep all of that in mind like you
there is a very good chance that you are
doing better than you think you are
um
then uh I think that another like
implication here is that
like there's a tendency I think for
people to give excessive deference to
people who are particularly strong or
who have a particularly good physique
um like people just assume that like
yeah if this person is really strong and
jacked they must know what they're
talking about
um or if someone isn't as strong and
isn't as jacked as someone else like oh
like they either don't know what they're
talking about or they're just not
putting in the work
and like I do think that that is
probably
directionally true on some level like I
I think if you took the entire universe
of people who deadlift 800 pounds and
the entire universe of people who
deadlift 200 pounds Ah that's not a
great example the 400 pounds the the 800
pound deadlifters do probably know more
about deadlifting on average than the
400 pound deadlifters do generally just
because I mean they've been they've been
doing it longer if they they're probably
com they're probably competing if they
pull 800 pounds so they've probably
devoted more time and headspace into
thinking about it and whatnot so like
there is probably that rough correlation
but it's
not nearly as strong of a correlation as
I think a lot of people assume like
there are a lot of very very bright
lifters and coaches who just didn't have
the best genetic draw for for lifting
and they know what they're doing uh
they're they're good like they're they
know how to train themselves or if
they're coaches they know how to train
other people but like they're not gonna
squat 800 bench 500 whatever just
because they didn't pick the right
parents for it and that's totally fine
so don't uh immediately assume someone
either isn't training hard or don't know
what they're talking about just because
they're not freaky huge freaky jacked
super strong and conversely don't
automatically assume someone knows what
they're talking about because they are
super strong or super jacked like there
are there are plenty of people who just
picked tremendously good parents for
resistance training who don't who don't
have any [ __ ] idea what they're doing
um yeah they just they just lucked into
a good situation uh
and then finally just just to recap like
if you are struggling with your results
some things that you could try to get
things moving in the right direction
uh one make sure you have your ducks in
a row outside the gym two just keep
training small gains do still add up
over time three uh if you have the the
motivation and capacity to do so in
general if you train more or train
harder that will tend to lead to better
results uh four measure more variables
like you know strength might be going
well even if you're not building a ton
of muscle or vice versa uh five
experiment with different training
Styles this does not conflict with
continuing to train you know you can
train more you can train harder you can
keep training but if none of that's
working just try training differently uh
there might be a different style of
training that you respond well to that
maybe does differ from the norms and
trust your own experiences there and and
don't be afraid to experiment and
troubleshoot
um
and uh
finally like
embrace the other benefits of training
Beyond
purely physical capacity slash body
shape those those gains in health
markers longevity uh Mental Health Sleep
Etc like those are real tangible
benefits that you can see from training
even if you're not putting on all of the
muscle you want to like it is still
doing beneficial things for you
um and you know if you feel like you're
banging your head against the wall and
you're not seeing the results you want
and you just don't like the training
you're doing there is absolutely nothing
wrong with just trying to find a
different
overall style of training that you both
respond better to and that you just like
doing more that you that you find more
kind of intrinsic enjoyment and and
ultimately that's going to be much more
strongly predictive of whether you do it
for a long time and whether you know
whether you stick with it long enough to
see notable benefits both physically and
in terms of you know mental health
longevity uh all of that other good
stuff